of Steel skilled enough
clear the nominees for best achievement
in directing Sam Mendes for American
Beauty Spike Jonze Levine John Malkovich
los the hallström for The Cider House
Rules Michael Mann for the insider M
night Shyamalan for The Sixth Sense
and the Oscar goes to Sam Mendes for
American Beauty
this is the first Oscar nomination for
British theatre director Sam Mendes
American Beauty is his film directorial
debut
I'm a little bit overwhelmed I want to
say huge respect first of all to the
fellow to my fellow nominees it's an
honor to be in your company genuinely
it's an honor to be here I want to say
thank you to an astonishing young studio
DreamWorks for having the courage to
hire a bloke from English theatre to do
a movie about American suburbia and then
trusting him so Thank You Glenn
Williamson Bob Cooper
Walter parts Laurie McDonald Jeffrey
Katzenberg David Geffen
Terry press and especially thank you to
Steven Spielberg for handing me the
script in the first place for handing me
this and for being so generous with your
wisdom thank you to a fantastic
fantastic cast of actors I will be
forever in your debt
thank you for giving so much of
yourselves to this picture particularly
Kevin and Annette and Chris Cooper and
the three younger actors Thank You Wes
and Thora and Mina thank you so much to
all the people my many many
collaborators on this movie
- Dan jinx and Bruce Cohen the producers
- Conrad Hall you're an artist and I
love you - Tom Newman for your fantastic
music - - Naomi show Hannah Julie vice
the designers - my personal heroes Beth
Swofford your fabulous and equally
fabulous Tyra cook to my editor tareeq
anwar - to all the people who work at
and have worked at the Donmar Warehouse
Theatre in London - all my friends at
home watching in my flat in Primrose
Hill have a drink for me too - my dad
and my stepmother watching back home in
South London - Alan Ball for a truly
original original screenplay and and
finally I'd like to say thank you to a
personal hero of mine who was a big
influence on this movie I want to say
thank you to Billy Wilder and I want to
say to him if my career after this point
amounts to one tenth of what yours has
been I will be a very happy man so to
all of those people and especially to
you to the Academy thank you so so much
you